thank you Paul Thank You Dean it's a
parent I have friends at Yale
and a Thursday maybe I should just stay
here on Thursday after back to
Washington where are there are those who
take a somewhat less elevated view of my
character and competence but anyway you
think you're going to get an answer to
this question I don't know why but this
introduction reminded me of an old story
people used to tell of Lyndon Johnson
during the Vietnam War which was not a
happy event for our country and during
that time he got into a fight with his
speechwriter and he had to give a speech
and he started reading from the cards
that the speechwriter had prepared and
they said now you may wonder how I'm
going to reconcile our aims of bringing
peace to Vietnam with my having sent
500,000 additional troops you may wonder
how I'm going to bring together our
lofty objectives in the world with the
terrible views that others are taking of
us because of this incident you may
wonder how I am going to reconcile the
terrible inflation the war has caused
with my desire to have social projects
that will make Americans better off and
he turns to the next card and it says I
quit you're on your own wise guy
so there we are now it's true yesterday
I was starting with an idea the idea is
a simple one that this Constitution was
meant to be workable that meant it isn't
just words on paper it's meant to work
for people in the United States and as
part of that part the framers thought or
many of them that it was a fairly good
idea to give the Supreme Court the power
to review the lawfulness of statutes
measured against the Constitution and it
is also true that they didn't seem to
ask the question of well if these people
are so unknot no purse no sword nobody's
heard of them they're just these
bureaucrats that sit there and decide
things and they'll try to be fair that's
about the most we can say for them they
will try to be fair and they won't
disturb us too often why would anyone on
these major issues that they feel so
unpopular so terrible so strongly and
maybe so wrongly decided they're all
thinking about the court my goodness why
will they ever do what the court says
and that was the question we asked and
then I gave some examples which of
course don't give an answer but are
meant to make you or others think about
the problem and think that we've come in
a certain sense a long way and we do
have a treasure there and so if you want
to know how are we going to get people
to continue to do this I hate to tell
you it isn't gonna have much to do with
the court it's going to have quite a lot
to do with the same question I get in
Europe I was at some event where they're
celebrating the 200th anniversary of the
French Civil Code and one of the
questions that comes up is one of the
people there the first question actually
by the way was he thought he said I I've
it's interesting I've I've learned that
we have put into this Civil Code after
200 years a lot of provisions that are
designed to give equality to women so
why is it in 202 days of many many
speeches praising the Civil Code there
hasn't been one woman who was invited to
give the speech is that and then he says
the second question is what do we do
with the Civil Code now that we're in a
world and the third question though how
do we teach the values in
Civil Code to our children and our
grandchildren
of course my reaction as then where am I
am I in the United States in France in
Boston in Paris where the same question
everywhere and that last one is the
question and the answer is going to be
we're gonna have to find a way to do it
because that's where the answer lies
it's not going to be in the court but
and it's a big but the court has its
responsibilities too and maybe the court
can help a little maybe and that's what
I want to talk about this afternoon if
the public generally has an obligation
to follow if we want to keep this
treasure then the court too has an
obligation well to do what and hear
immediately we'll start into controversy
because in my mind what the court has
the obligation to do is to make
decisions that will work well for people
interpret the law in ways that will work
well for today's public so already we're
too abstract luckily have about 200
pages making this more concrete but
nonetheless I won't tell you all those
pages abstract try to create decisions
that work well for people here in the
United States hmm
what is that to do with yesterday well
if you do they're more likely to I think
what you're doing is okay and if they
think what you're doing is okay they may
have more pride in the institution and
if they have more pride in confidence in
the institution then maybe they'll tend
to continue what we said yesterday was a
treasure in effect well that's the
connection but let's go back to this
very abstract phrase now I can make it a
little bit less abstract I can say that
if I want to describe this general
approach I would probably describe it is
taking in the Constitution at least
certain values that are permanent but
don't change and applying them to a
world the change is continuously you
know you say okay that sounds good
enough at least for fourth of July or
something but I mean that's pretty
abstract too well let's try and make it
a little more concrete what about saying
that there really isn't an overall
pragmatic approach to the Constitution
it isn't true I don't think it's true
that any one or very few would look at a
decision and then decision by decision
say I want to see here which will be
best
what will produce the best result that
leaves out what you're going to law
school for three years to learn it's
called law law is a very complex set of
interrelated institutions it involves
some words and statutes it involves a
Constitution it involves a common law it
involves law firms it involves hundreds
of different institutions all of which
interact in some complex way and if
suddenly you have a judge coming in and
just saying oh I'm just gonna do
whatever I think is good case by case
that is not going to work in my opinion
very well but still but still I think
there are a set of pragmatic approaches
that may help well that's good because
that's pretty vague too so I can say
what I'm doing this afternoon is giving
you an introduction to a pragmatic no to
an approach to a set of pragmatic
approaches and by the time you figure
that out the hour will be over and I
won't have to say another word all right
now let me say what it isn't let me say
whatever what is it it means my looking
back over 15 years of experience in the
court and trying to ask myself the
question are the decisions that I've
tended to make is the view that I've
tended to take towards different
problems is it really just ad hoc
one by one or can I characterize it does
it fall into categories and are there
reasons why I think that these
categories might be better rather than
worse categories that's what I've tried
to do and I think the answer is yes I
can I can to a degree and that's what I
want to talk about what isn't this
approach I can tell you what it isn't
for one thing it is not whatever is
signified by this word called original
what is originalism wait something tying
back and I don't want to characterize it
because I don't follow it too much and
therefore I don't want to be too mean to
the people who do think it provides a
terrific solution and they're good
arguments for it but I don't find it
very attractive as an approach really
for a number of reasons it's looking
back to seeing what would James Madison
have said or what would Alexander
Hamilton have said and I see nothing
wrong with that if what you're trying to
do is understand the basic value
underlying this particular part of the
Constitution but when you get want to
get specific answers from Hamilton or
from Madison or from their
contemporaries I find that difficult I
find it difficult first of all because
the real cases that come up they didn't
say too much about I mean we have a
confrontation clause
the confrontation Clause says that you
have to confront witnesses accused
person has to have an opportunity to
confront witnesses well that has
something to do with Sir Walter Raleigh
oddly enough who was convicted because
they brought into court some statements
made by witnesses out of court that had
been signed and when Sir Walter Raleigh
says bring them in they say oh we're
sorry we lost them we'll give you the
statements but we can't give you the
people so we know that this has
something to do with that
but a case comes up and says what about
a woman who tells a policeman that her
husband has been beating her up and then
three days later she's found dead and
the husbands put on trial can we admit
that or not does the confrontation
Clause forbid it or not because she's
not there to be confronted anymore she's
been killed hmm let's ask Madison
he doesn't say can we ask Sir Walter
Raleigh he's gone
not even Blackstone tells us the answer
to that and I've just given you an
example because I think that the
statement was well made by justice
Jackson he says often he says that
history he says enigmatic as Joseph's
that's good I like that good phrase and
he had many good phrases and that's one
of his better ones and I will have to
say subjectively case after case after
case well I find that history pretty and
agentic and if we want to decide on the
basis of what Madison would have said
about such a thing if anybody ever asked
him and it never did let's hire nine
historians and not nine judges because
the historians will fight but it's at
least possible
they'll come closer to the right answer
but a more important reason I think as
to why I find it so difficult to follow
is because often the relevant fault of
the framer is not really exactly how
they would have decided this case it's
often what kind of a provision they were
writing and what I mean by that is if
you see the word two senators in the
Constitution that doesn't mean three it
didn't mean three then it didn't mean
three now and you can change the world
as much as you like it's never going to
mean three but when you see the words
interstate commerce you can't be certain
but you probably think that the framers
intended the content of those words to
change over time they didn't know that
we were going to have the internet or
television but they thought that these
words will pick up now fill in the blank
but we do know that the most that they
could have thought of is the words will
have different content as time
progresses and that's true of a lot of
words in the Constitution then those who
wrote the 14th amendment who saw
segregated schools and who didn't think
apparently that these words are going to
stop segregated schools at least not now
ah did they think at least not now and
did they think that as time changes if
things don't work out and we end up with
the South that we ended up with in 1953
but now it will pick up segregated
schools and stop them I think that
absolutely
I think that absolutely and that's
pretty Universal but note the nature of
that intent the intent was to serve a
purpose a certain kind of purpose and
when that purpose is not served the
content of what fills in the blank of
what's forbidden or not changes in light
of what the overall purpose was is this
a provision that changes or is it not a
provision that changes and often they
don't express if you on that any more
than they expressed a view about whether
originalism or something else would be
the right way to interpret the
Constitution they said not a word about
it then another reason that I don't
particularly favor this particular
approach is because often it seems to me
it's not very transparent that is at
least if you're uncertain and at least
if you see a lot of purposes going in
different directions and you see
precedent going in different directions
and you see consequences that will come
out one way or the other and you want to
write about those because you think
you're relevant you write about them and
a person reads that opinion and he says
how wrong Breyer was or sometimes how
right but he can least see exactly what
I'm thinking but if you're trying to
write about what say I 19th century
early 19th century judge thought about
what Blackstone who's an 18th century
writer thought about what happened in
the English Civil War is in the 17th
century and the historians disagree it's
a little hard to know sometimes just
what this judge is driving at is the
ball being hidden or is it not and all
we can talk about is the history and
then a fourth reason and now I'm coming
to the main point is if in fact well
that were the Constitution if in fact
that is what we're supposed to do if in
fact it turns out that there was
flogging in the Navy in 1780 and that
means that it's ok not cruel and unusual
punishment to flawed people today or if
in a society that people hoped would
evolve in 1865 just after the Civil War
they thought maybe there will be
segregated schools for a while and that
means we're supposed to keep them for
all time
well if that were the approach why would
people want this Constitution why would
they want a constitution today that did
things like that
so I would say if we're going to go back
to yesterday's talk there are at least
some reasons for saying originalism is
not the approach to follow unfortunately
you haven't heard the defense of
originalism and I'm not going to bother
to defend it today but there is
something to be said for it and that is
those who advocated say at least it's
definite at least it stops the judge
from running wild with his own views of
what's good I don't really think that so
but that's the line to me that's been
the strongest line of defense well if
you're not going to have originalism
then what's the judge supposed to do how
is he supposed to decide these cases in
general and I'll tell you what most
people think and probably in the corner
of your mind there's a little bit of
this too and I've probably reinforced it
a little bit with what I said yesterday
well I'll tell you who these judges are
in Washington in that building
they're Junior League politicians they
ought to look to politics and my
goodness I can tell you how many times
that I've seen people say to me oh I
love your decisions and I have a feeling
they might think politically that
they're on the same side maybe we are
and maybe we're not or I can't bear
those decisions and they're thinking
well politically I don't agree because
really what the Supreme Court is is 9
politicians who are not that good at
being politicians otherwise they'd have
been elected to something and they never
would have been there but nonetheless
that's what they try well that can't be
right that can't be right despite
everything I said yesterday because if
what you're supposed to do
is stick up your finger to the political
winds well then why have a Supreme Court
then Hamilton was basically wrong in
putting this power of review in a court
if he wanted a politician let's get some
give the power to Congress but it can't
be right but the judges should sit there
and test out the political wind well if
it's not going to be the political wind
and if it's not going to be a definite
thing like originalism what is it well
maybe it's just doing what you think is
good that's where I started after all
and I said that won't work and by the
way ten minutes is fast or seven anyway
and I still don't think it'll work
because if you get nine people up there
and they're all trying to do whatever
they think is good in a particular
instance you will discover they disagree
all the time and indeed different people
think different things are particularly
good and certainly over time you won't
get very much coherence but that's what
people think they think either they're
up there deciding what they think is
good or they're acting like Junior
League politicians and not telling us
the truth about what that or we better
have a definite theory like originalism
and originalism isn't perfect but it'll
least hold them in check now do I have a
better defense of originalism say and
that's what's going on I think in the
minds of people what a hold that
particular point of view but as I said I
don't think it works so is there another
different point of view an approach well
obviously I think there is or wouldn't
give this lecture but what what and now
we're back to where I started and I'm
back to what I called pragmatism or a
certain kind of pragmatic approach and I
found some fairly good historical
support for this Gordon wood in a very
good recent book traces back to 1798 the
following fall a judge called route from
Connecticut he said
what American judges do and this is 1798
so what American judges do when they're
interpreting the law and trying to get a
sensible interpretation is they look to
quote the reasonableness and utility of
the operation of those principles of law
that's not bad I like that as immediate
residence for me and moreover I think
over time we've seen judges trying to do
that and we read what frankfurter tried
to describe he was doing where we read
that learn at hand thought compared
interpreting a statute to interpreting a
musical score to try to get what was the
root of this there are lots of things
that were written probably more when I
was in law school than even today that
suggests a certain pragmatic utilitarian
reasonableness approach in American law
and it's that approach that I'm trying
to describe well what is it well it puts
a lot of weight on purposes and
consequences it looks to the basic
values that underlie constitutional
provisions it looks to I think the fact
that when they wrote the document the
framers created several institutions of
government and they expected that those
different institutions of government
while balancing each other to some
degree would work together in order to
produce a government as a whole that
worked well for Americans well we're
making a little advance not too much
will this put judges out of control if
they try to work on some kind of
pragmatic basis well they suddenly and
secretly substitute their own desires
there are lots of checks there are lots
of checks on judges not the least of
which is that they have to write an
opinion and the opinion if it's a good
opinion has to explain the true reasons
why they reach the decision the decision
has to be reasoned
it has to be principled it has to be
transparent it has to be informative and
in doing that it has to follow or
explain why not what I'd call a hole
maybe thousands at least hundreds of
prescriptions of the legal craft you
learn that in law school and then you
put those together and I think you have
some content to what learn at hand
answered when he was asked these
questions
Ronnie Dworkin says that I don't know
who asked him maybe Ronnie asked him but
what is it that keeps you in check those
books he said those books and he meant a
lot more than precedent he meant some of
the things I've just mentioned in
general terms and then two judges create
what Sandra O'Connor called footsteps I
first get to the court I decide some
cases I create approaches out of the
fact that I've decided those cases and I
don't like very much to deviate from an
approach I first took why not well
because if I can deviate too much from
an approach I first took well then
there's no control over anything then it
really is up to me subjectively though I
feel it's never up to me subjectively
I'm following more all right well so far
what I've done is I've described and I'm
trying very generally to describe in
abstract terms in a lot of words things
that are getting you to think about a
particular approach and sometimes I
analogize that the arguments among
judges to a kind of moral argument what
do we do when we have a moral argument
with somebody what do we do when we have
an argument about something with someone
about what the right thing to do next
the right thing to do is to take him to
the movies I can't stand him do I have
to take him to the movies well think of
all he did for you all right so now
we're arguing about this and is it right
or is it wrong and what we do is we
refer to principles and then we refer
facts and then we refer to consequences
and then we're back at principles and
the argument gets all mixed up between
principles between facts between
predictions about what will happen about
what we did before and if you start
thinking about that it's pretty similar
to the kinds of arguments that go on in
court
oh dear this is all so complicated can I
try to make it simpler all right let me
try to do this and let me take 15 or 20
minutes maybe a little longer giving you
some examples of what I mean is up there
at the top level I think of the words
principles that don't change applying to
circumstances that do and I think of the
words a set of institutions not one
that's supposed to cooperate with each
other to try to produce results that the
government as a whole will work well for
people and then I think but you can't
decide cases bit by bit and then I've
learned over time at least it seems to
me that there are sets of attitudes the
judges can take in respect to particular
kinds of cases that don't guarantee
wonderful results in any every any any
particular case but over time help
produce better results because over time
they help the court work better with
some other institution now I'll give you
an example in fact they'll give you
eight or nine examples of different but
I'm only going to really talk about two
in depth that will give you an examples
of what I mean by attitudes not theories
that help guide judges towards decisions
that work better as a whole other
institutions being relevant well what is
most of our work most of our work in the
Supreme Court actually deals with
Congress we have lots of relationships
with Congress the normal relationship
concerns statutes and normally what
we're doing is interpreting statutes so
if I say our relationship with Congress
has to do with
and the question before us is how do we
interpret statutes I would say the key
pragmatics concept towards
interpretation of statutes pretty
well-known is called the statutes
purpose what does that mean well all
judges whatever they interpret a statute
have the same basic tools they read the
language they look at the history they
look at tradition if it's a word like
race it's a loquitur or something you
don't know what that means you look up
the tradition you look at precedent you
look at the purpose of the statute and
you look at the consequences the
consequence is judged in terms of the
purpose and that's what helps you find
an interpretation and what I'd say here
is emphasize those latter two purposes
and consequences particularly in the
Supreme Court because the others will
help you a lot less now what's a typical
statutory problem so we can make this
more concrete I found a good example in
a newspaper abroad it turns out
apparently there was a man who was going
from Normandy he was a schoolteacher and
he was going from Normandy to Paris and
he taught biology and he had a basket
and he had two dozen live snails in the
basket the conductor came up said open
the basket please saw the snails and
said you have to pay half fare for the
snails who said we didn't have to pay
half fare for the snails he said we'll
read the tariff the tariff here says no
pets no animals sorry no animals allowed
on the train except in a basket and if
they're in a basket they have to pay
half fare he said snails snails have to
pay half fare well it's a little
puzzling isn't it do they have to pay
half fairies don't they I don't know and
by the way why just one half fare there
were twenty I mean you say now there is
the kind of question we're likely to get
in the Supreme Court of the United
States
now maybe not in that as exact words but
we have to figure that one out and you
try figuring it out by looking at the
history without understanding alright go
on to a different example here's a real
one you can sue the government if they
take your property wrongly and or if
they hurt you it's called the tort
claims that now there's an exception and
the exception is if the person who takes
that properly wrongfully is any quote
any officer of customs or excise or any
other law enforcement officer hmm any
other law enforcement officer does that
mean a prison official does it mean a
policeman on the corner or does it mean
those other law enforcement officers
that have something to do with Customs
and Excise hmm not such an easy question
well how are we gonna find out the
answer should we look in the dictionary
which word didn't you know the meaning
of is it you didn't know the meaning of
an e or other or law or enforcement or
officer which word will the dictionary
help you with I think it will help or
let's do this let's say how are these
words used in ordinary life well I don't
know I mean what part of ordinary life I
mean in a movie what's the title I mean
when I go down the street what again I
don't think I'm helped very much well
let's look at them very hard let's look
at them two or three times sound them to
the ear is that going to help you see
I'm very skeptical now I have an idea
there is a human being who wrote those
words maybe if we can find out who that
human being is and what that human being
had in mind we can answer the question
and lo and behold who it turned out to
be was a man called Holtz off a road of
Fame
Street is Varon and holds often he was
sitting in the Justice Department and he
actually kept notes and wrote a letter
to Congress of how he found those words
and he was copying an English statute at
the time and when you looked at the
English statute it was absolutely clear
that that English statute applied to
customs policemen and it did not apply
to prison officials or anybody else at
least I thought it was pretty clear and
at least whoever joined my descent
thought it was pretty clear okay so why
will I do this
why why I've shown you the other doesn't
work too well but the purpose doesn't
always work too well I think why do it
why's try so hard and I have said this I
look anywhere I wanted somebody wrote
those words find that person see what
they had in mind why do I do that well
there's some reasons I think are pretty
good and one of the reasons is this I
know that the people who wrote these
words in Congress were elected by
somebody and those who elect them don't
have a clue about this kind of thing
their electors their voters but they do
have a sort of clue about what kind of
country they want and they have general
objectives and the congressman or
senator who flies in the face of the
general objectives that his constituents
want is going to find himself out of the
job pretty quickly so the good
politicians who actually get themselves
elected do have a pretty keen sense of
what the general objectives are that
members of their constituencies or
majorities hold now if those
constituencies elect somebody to do
something and then he participates in
the writing of a statute that has a
particular objective then let the court
try to interpret that statute in a way
that carries out that does not fly in
the face of that does not wreck this
individual congressman's effort to
achieve that general objective through
this statute now the reason in part is
democratic theory but the reason in part
is very practical because if this
statute doesn't work out
if this statute wrecks the general
objective that that voter wanted let's
be sure that that congressman or senator
has to take the blame for it and can't
say oh it was the court you know they
wrecked it they interpreted that word
law enforcement officer you for people
who have real interest in this in my
constituency but but don't let them say
it was the court that erected the court
tries to carry out the purposes that are
underlying this statute oh well there
are other reasons too I mean really I
think one of the best ones does it make
up maybe Congress understands the
problem that they're trying to deal with
better than we do that's their job after
all and so let them try to pursue this
objective that they have in this statute
in a lot of different ways and let us
try to understand what the objective is
and assume that what they're trying to
do there is to further their own
objective and not direct it that helps
and now what I think helps too is it
helps that Congress doesn't have to fill
in every detail
they can't life is too uncertain you
can't write everything into a statute
now all you have to do in order to know
that which is not a new discovery is
read which I found exactly the argument
in Montaigne 1584 great essay on
experience I thought of showing it to
some of my colleagues here's what he
says he says you know he says I'd rather
live in a country with no laws at all
than live in a country with too many
laws like France he says this is what
happened Justinian was furious with the
judges that is a sound familiar
Justinian was furious with the judges
because they're always doing what they
want rather than what he wants so here's
what he thinks of doing he thinks of
writing a code that's really complicated
and has thousands you know it'll get
into every situation and it'll say do
this here and do that there and do the
other thing in the other place and now
we've got them and the judges have to
follow it they can't just do it
and Montaigne says didn't he know that
every written word is simply one more
subject of an argument among lawyers and
when you write all those words you are
not gonna give the judges less power you
are going to give them more power so
that's why I don't want to live in
France anymore too many laws but wait
there is an intermediate solution and
that intermediate solution says
Montaigne is have a few laws a few
principles standards objectives written
into the statute and let the judges then
interpret those words so that the
statutes purposes standards etc are
carried out now I have to admit but I'm
putting a little bit of gloss on
Montaigne but if you read it you'll see
I think but that's his basic point oh
wait there are objections there are
objections to this approach I'm not
being fair to the objections and I'm
gonna no I'm not gonna be fair than to Y
be fair what you means as the objector
you're saying members in Congress
Congress has a purpose Congress doesn't
have a purpose members of Congress
individuals might have purposes but
their purpose might be to vote for
something as fast as possible so I can
get to lunch their purpose might be I'm
voting for this in order to wreck my
opponent and wreck the whole bill it's a
poison pill amendment who knows what
their purposes are it isn't really true
that only individuals have purposes so I
made a list of some things that have
purposes that aren't individuals and
then I had animals either not even
snails I mean what corporations have
purposes companies partnerships
municipalities states nations armies bar
associations legislatures basketball
teams football teams and many others do
we know how to speak English yes do we
know how to ascribe purposes to such
entities absolutely can we ascribe
purposes to Congress yes if we go to law
school read enough legislation have good
professor's of which you do hear of
legislative courses and have a little
bit of experience we then begin to learn
how this all works and there's nothing
odd about saying the basketball team did
that in order to prevent the other team
from having too much possession of the
ball even if not one of those five
people did anything but operate
mechanically and was thinking of the
latest movie at the time of course we
can say that oh wait it's too hard to
figure out what the purposes are it's
very hard we don't really know what
Congress's purposes are and the judge
will just describe any purpose that he
wants to some kind of statutory language
and they're right it is sometimes hard
sometimes hard but let me tell you a
joke and then you tell me why it's funny
here is the joke there are three men in
a balloon they're lost they descend just
above the ground they see a farmer this
is in Maine it's an old Maine joke one
of them says to the farmer where are we
the farmer answers in a balloon idath
big was that funny but you see why is
that a joke when you see why that's a
joke you'll see why in fact it often is
not hard really hard to ascribe purposes
to what other people do or what
corporations do or what Congress does
when Joanna says to me there's no butter
she doesn't mean there's no butter in
Cambridge Massachusetts or Washington DC
she means there's no butter in the house
how do we know that because we speak
English because we understand how to
derive what people intend from the
context we use context every day of the
week we use context every time we open
our mouths to understand other people we
listen and we know English and we apply
the words and so why is it such an odd
thing
for such a difficult thing in case after
case to do the same thing with statutes
now you see oh it's all to the
legislative history that's another good
one
the legislative history which I look to
but reports the reports the floor
statements all those things I said
holtzoff was his first name Barinholtz
offer was there another person called
Baron I had to forget that but it
Alex hold saw he was in his office in
the Justice Department I read his letter
maybe he was writing a letter to confuse
me maybe an assistant was writing the
letter and didn't get it right but was
pushing his own agenda maybe somebody in
the congressional staff was doing it in
order to mix everybody up doesn't this
give too much power to the staff not
member of Congress well I worked on the
staff you know so I have a biased view
on that one and I think that the staffs
are pretty great people as far as I can
tell and I do know this I worked for
Senator Kennedy for quite a long time
and if I tried to substitute my agenda
for his I'd be out of a job pretty fast
and I know the way that we used to
decide what to write in reports drafts
of reports were circulated they're
circulated to every member of Congress
on the committee and the committee has
staff that reads the report and the job
of the staff person is to see if that
report is basically consistent with what
his boss thinks and if he thinks that it
isn't consistent he'll point it out and
if he thinks it's something important
he'll tell the boss so you better get
back into this and see what's going on
here but that's why he's hired
that's how staffs work that's how staffs
work in Congress that's how they work in
General Motors that's how they work in
businesses that's how they work even in
universities though the professor is
pretty autonomous in the university but
nonetheless there are all kinds of
institutions with staffs and the senator
is responsible for the staff so what is
what is the big problem now you see I'm
giving you a sketch but the sketch is
that purpose is going to help why is it
going to help it's going to help because
it's going to help make
representative democratically
responsible to his electorate and that's
a good thing and a good way to get
things done in a democracy and it's
going to help because those staffs
when they write bills are not going to
have to think of every possible thing in
advance they're going to be able to use
a few general words and they're going to
be able to explain what they're driving
at if necessary in a report right there
we are and yet we have a case and the
case was that a person a person who has
a child who is handicapped can get a
pretty good education for that child
it's called to all education for all the
handicapped a great act very good
sometimes the school board makes what
could be a mistake and doesn't give that
person that child the education to which
they're entitled in which case the
parent can go and hire a lawyer and some
experts and now sue the school board and
now what happens if the parent wins well
the child to get the better education
but the parents out an awful lot of
money well the statute says the parent
can recover reasonable attorneys fees
good she can pay the attorney but what
about the expert the expert in this case
is is all important and the expert cost
twenty thirty forty fifty thousand
dollars it's quite a lot of work now it
happens the statute just says including
reasonable attorneys fees costs
including reasonable attorneys fees does
that include the expert - hmm well let's
look at the report the report addresses
the point the report of who the report
of the conference committee between the
Senate and House that ended up with the
final language and they said we mean to
include experts and then the bill went
back for a vote and everybody has the
cannot saying they'll all read the
conference report but that was on the
agenda and they're supposed to vote on
it and they voted on it and they adopted
that report which had that language this
is the way you adopt language the to
compromise in the Senate and they did
that unanimously nobody objected I say
can we not read that can we no look at
it does it not give us an idea of what
we were thinking okay I thought it did
I thought we looked to the purpose I
thought we find the purpose wherever we
want and any of those who agreed with me
joined the dissent okay so there we are
so you see what I'm trying to illustrate
here I'm trying to illustrate there is
an approach it doesn't answer every
question but there's an approach it
starts with a P and it ends with E it's
called purpose and that helps in an
awful lot of cases and not just deciding
this but deciding it in a way that
advances the workability of the system
now I can go through a lot of other
examples but I won't in that death but I
have divided it in courting to the kind
of work we have in the relation to the
institution for example a subject I like
hardly anyone else does is
administrative law I taught that for
years an administrative law really has
to do with the relationship between the
judges now and the executive branch
because most of what the executive
branch of does is administration so the
bulk of our work there is reviewing the
work of that administrative branch to
see what to see if it conforms well is
it does it conform to the statute does
it conform to the regulations does it
conform to a few common law principles
did they apply proper procedure is the
policy that they've developed reasonable
or is it arbitrary capricious is it
constitutional there are a number of
things that we review to see how do we
do that and here I have a concept and
the concept developed out of the 30s 40s
50s and 60s when judges tried to develop
a relationship
legally speaking with the people in the
administrative branch of government and
if I look back at that I would say it
consists of two words plus another plus
two others the two words being
comparative expertise who is the better
expert at this kind of question you or
the agency
so if it's a question to procedure
courts there quite a lot about procedure
if it's a question of the Constitution
they're supposed to know really quite a
lot comparatively speaking if it's a
question of the policy that the statute
is trying to further
well the agencies are usually experts in
that and so courts back away stay a
little bit away from that if it's a
question of the statutes meaning well
you might think about corporations I'm
sorry
courts are pretty expert at statutes
isn't that their job well try reading a
few of those statutes try reading
thousands and thousands of words there
and you'll see an awful lot of statutes
that really no one can understand too
well except for the agency that happens
to work with them every day and a lot of
those words govern very minor matters
within the agency and so there has been
developed a view which we hold at the
court that even on certain statutory
matters give the agency the benefit of
the doubt give them the benefit of the
doubt when they interpret the statute
EPA wants to have what used to be called
a bubble a bubble the bubble was we're
not gonna regulate the smoke coming out
of any sac we're going to pretend
there's a bubble over the factory and
choose your own stack but the total
amount within the bubble has to stay
constant do they have the power to do
that well says our court it's a question
of what the statute says but they know
the statute here better than we do and
Congress meant to give them a bit of
power to interpret that statute as they
wish you see they know more about it we
give it to them but wait we better look
at the statute so in any case what I'm
saying there is it's not just
comparative expertise its comparative
expertise viewed in light of the
particular statute and what was its
purpose so if you have a statute that
says for example EPA you in fact have to
you don't have to but you have the power
to you have the power to make rules
concerning what's the word air
pollutants does that include carbon
dioxide on the one hand they know a lot
more about carbon dioxide than we do on
the other hand that's an awfully big
question it's a pretty major question
under this statute so in any case our
court seeing that word in the statute
and seeing the question begins to think
is this the kind of question that
Congress would have wanted the agency to
have a leg up in deciding and on that
one we said no on the bubble we said yes
hmm what's going on well what I think is
going on is this that we live in a world
where the technicality is unbelievable
there's chemistry there are pollutants
there are as everything is related to
everything else and everything is
incredibly complicated and we need
expert agencies we need people there to
regulate things and they're always going
to know a lot more than judges about
their own particular subject matter but
they have a particular problem which is
they tend to think whatever they're
doing like all human beings think is the
most important thing in the world and
therefore they can get carried away so
judges keep them under control agencies
go do your job but what's the right
attitude in particular cases that the
judge should take to the agency how much
leeway should he give it well there's a
problem here if you give the agencies
too much leeway to do things
goodbye democracy you'll have us run by
the bureaucrats but if you give them too
little leeway you will discover you
can't get anything done because when you
tell them exactly what to do direct you
regulate so2 X or whatever it is up to
such-and-such a degree you may discover
that's the wrong exactly the wrong thing
to tell them we don't tell the army what
Hills to take in China in legislation
and so you have to give the agency
leeway and to make a long story short
who decides how much the way they get
Congress and where does it say it in the
statute and what words does it used who
knows it never focuses on the question
but the question the judge will ask is
looking at this statute and considering
the comparative expertise of the
agencies to answer this question the
question arising on
this statute let's give the agency the
degree of leeway that Congress likely
would have intended given its purpose
and then decide what's necessary to hold
them in check
now that's complicated but it creates a
relationship it creates a relationship
between court agency and Congress and
that relationship has as its objective
allowing better functioning of a complex
administrative system in the democracy
that has to be ultimately responsible to
the people I'm not gonna convince you of
that in two minutes and indeed that is
the most difficult most boring part of
this entire book but I wanted to mention
it so we get through the worst part
first
now what about federalism again I think
they're interesting simple concepts I'm
just giving you a summary of what I've
written what concept why do we have
federalism what is federalism and I
think there are probably if you look
through the cases and look at the
history the things that made the most
impression upon me one of them was what
Madison said Madison said you know
there's a difference between Europe and
the United States in Europe its power
that creates Liberty in the United
States
it's Liberty that creates power and what
he meant by that is that in Europe at
that time it was the king you see where
the power was at the center and they
might if they had a liberal king or if
they had some kind of central government
that wanted free people allow freedom to
the people that's the opposite of the
American idea the American idea was that
power rested in the people of free
people that's what he has in mind by
Liberty and it's that Liberty that
delegates to the center namely federal
land namely the federal government the
authority that it has to do things the
residual part rests in the people now
that's the theory of it
the practical part is that very often
people in a lot of practical ideas
people who are in small towns and cities
or large towns they know more about
their mayor or the fire department or
the police department than people in
Washington or at least they can hold
them more directly responsible or
there's a classical idea that Brandeis
said if you add a lot of states put them
together they can experiment with a lot
of different ways there are a number of
practical ideas here and what does it
tell us about the court when I put them
together I see a word that they use in
Europe which we don't use here very much
but it's a pretty good word and it's
called some city arity and it says that
in fact power will should be given at
whatever level is the lowest level that
can exercise it effectively don't put it
at a more central place than you have to
that's great advice and the judges point
of view they have no idea how to apply
it why because we're applying it in a
world where every where everything is
related to everything else follow that
through and you'll see some consequences
the consequences from my point of view
is it has to be very very very rare that
we will overturn a congressional
judgment to take power and to pass
legislation because everything affects
everything they're more likely to know
than we it also suggests when we're
trying to do an undoubtedly federal
function protect the federal marketplace
we have to be a little more active and
in that area courts and Congress and
other agencies look for ways of
cooperating and I don't think I'll go
into them but there are ways and then
this idea of subsidiarity if you like or
federalism plays a role in a lot of
cases where it might not seem to play a
role for example one case I felt pretty
strongly about was a case involving
efforts by Seattle and by Louisville to
apply affirmative action plans
well affirmative action plans the court
said they couldn't do it I wrote partly
in my dissent but my goodness no one
knows here what's going to work there a
problem
they're undoubtedly problems and why is
it a bad idea to let at least in limited
ways different communities experiment
with different ways of dealing with
these problems including affirmative
action well that's a federalism idea
that's a subsidiarity idea and you can
look through cases in the court and
you'll see this subsidiary idea the
subsidiarity idea affecting quite a lot
of cases what about the relationship to
other federal courts there I think that
what's at stake is not other federal
courts lower courts what people see they
see trial courts appeals courts the
Supreme Court and they think it's a
hierarchy that's a misleading concept a
better concept a very practical concept
is to think of the word specialization
and to think that people at different
levels have different jobs and if you
think of the people at different levels
having different jobs then you ask the
question what's the Supreme Court's job
our Supreme Court's job basically
basically it's to resolve legal
questions where the lower courts have
come to different conclusions on matters
of federal law because we need a uniform
federal law and the Supreme Court
doesn't do that too badly but if you ask
the Supreme Court to start
second-guessing every Court of Appeals
in the country or if you ask them to
start looking at things that the trial
courts are particularly good at like
managing managing litigation deciding
what kind of discoveries appropriate
deciding things about individual
witnesses and if you ask the Supreme
Court to start reading records and
coming to a conclusion out of reading a
record you're going to have a pretty
hard time because the court isn't very
good at reading records because they're
nine of us and you might get nine
different opinions and you might not
have time for everybody really to go
into each record with the depth that it
deserves therefore I'd say look
specialization leave reading records to
the trial courts not to the Supreme
Court let the Supreme Court primarily
folk
on deciding legal issues but anyway the
word that I think works there is called
specialization what about the courts
relationship with prior Court's prior
Court's prior Supreme Court's the word
that describes that relationship is
called starry decisis that has to do
with overturning prior precedent how do
we go about that
there I think if you want a concept the
concept has to be something to do with
stability and it has to have something
to do with pragmatism because you can't
find a general rule that applies every
to every case you can't even easily find
a set of principles that tells you when
to overturn cases and when not
for example Brown versus Board
overturned Plessy versus Ferguson Plessy
versus Ferguson said separate but equal
brown v board after eight years figured
out that that was a mistake and I think
they're very few people alive now who
think it was wrong I mean it was ripe
for overturning and should have been
overturned but you can get carried away
with this overturning things and why
might a judge in our court get carried
away with overturning things one reason
is because judges on our court stay
there a long time and they are appointed
by different presidents and different
presidents have different points of view
and a president who tries to appoint a
Supreme Court justice whom he thinks
will decide his way on all kinds of
cases is in for a rude surprise when
Theodore Roosevelt appointed Oliver
Wendell Holmes Oliver Wendell Holmes
within months decided the way Roosevelt
thought was completely wrong in northern
securities an antitrust case and
Roosevelt said I could I could carve a
judge with more backbone out of a banana
right he was annoyed and Holmes never
understood why Roosevelt stopped
inviting him to parties at the White
House was absolutely true ah but if you
think a president might try to appoint
someone who
shares a kind of very basic very
abstract outlook about how the country
works about how the law works about the
relation of law to individuals or to the
country presidents tend to have more
success at that and therefore if people
are there for a long time you'll get
people with pretty different general
abstract philosophical points of view
and now what will happen each of those
people will think that he's right
I mean why was he appointed the Supreme
Court if he isn't right I mean he's
right and there's a lot of precedent out
there that's wrong and we've got to get
back to the true Constitution so thanks
each of different views I'm right we
better get back to the true Constitution
which all this precedents got mixed up
because it was decided by people of
different views and probably for other
reasons they may just be mistaken and in
addition a point that you don't realize
until you're there for a while you're
not gonna get another chance an issue
comes up and it's very easy in a court
of appeals to think Oh it'll come back
it'll come back
don't worry to get this wrong come back
it won't come back it won't come back in
the Supreme Court so here we have this
right in front of us a very important
matter and my goodness it was wrongly
decided before and my goodness I
understand the Constitution indeed I've
just been appointed and I better make it
right now if I don't make it right now
I'll never have another chance you see
the psychology I'm not saying everyone
has that psychology but there's an
institutional push in that direction and
the problem is resisted resist it and
how can you resist it because you're not
going to resist it all the time and the
answer is to focus your mind on the need
for stability in a legal system and that
need for stability is great it has many
parts to it you can't go around every
day of the week and start overturning
things you think we're wrong or there
won't be much of a legal system left and
people won't be able to live underneath
it and therefore resist how far how far
should do resist
well far enough I mean what's the answer
to that I can't tell you it's a
pragmatic thing that people have to work
out for themselves but if you go too far
you're gonna wreck the system and if you
don't go far enough you can end up with
Plessy v Ferguson you say I can outline
the problem and I can tell you the
approach and I can't always get you to
the answer it's hard enough to get to
the answer all right so what have we
been through you've seen the statutory
part and purpose you've seen the
administrative law at least got a
glimpse of it you've seen the federalism
idea you've seen treating other courts
as specialization and not real horror
Archy you've seen the prior court is
treated in terms of what stability but
with a pragmatic cast applying to it and
then they're an awful lot of cases that
involve not just other institutions but
involve all institutions and all
institutions are under an obligation to
follow certain basic protections that we
have for individual rights and they're I
think - there's an approach it's not a
guarantee it's an approach that looks to
the value that underlies the particular
provision of the Constitution and tries
to apply that value to modern
circumstance and an awful lot of these
provisions and an awful lot of them
require a degree of balancing because
even the first amendment sacred though
it is can not be enough to protect
against a law for example or that law
stops somebody from killing somebody
where of consider espionage laws I
consider a lot of laws where are you
regulate what people can say because the
consequence of not doing so is viewed as
too terrible how do we know which or
which how do we know what to do when
privacy and First Amendment values
conflict etc again there's an approach
and one I don't think I like to call it
I like to call it proportionality and
there's a whole system I wrote about it
unfortunately in a dissent in the gun
control
case but there we are there are
approaches and now let me now describe
one last one a greater length because
it's less technical it may have more
interest and it's harder to figure out
what to do what about the relation of
the court to the President himself where
does that come up legally it comes up in
areas where the president has enormous
power as president not just as
administrator and the place where it
comes up recently that I think has been
of the greatest interest is of course in
the area of national security because
the president's power is great in the
area of national security and there the
notion the approach the idea that I
think a pragmatic court is trying to
carry out is called this it's called
keep the president accountable but wait
not too much he does have to protect the
nation so I sort of think of it and it
was in the Guantanamo cases as a kind of
accountability tug on a string now let
me tell you about two cases or two sets
of cases and you'll see what I mean
about the difficulty here the first is
1946 was a 4444 Korematsu how did the
court get into this mess Korematsu is a
case were 70,000 American citizens were
taken without a trial without any real
procedure and put in camps for the
duration of the war they were Japanese I
mean they were of Japanese ancestry but
they were American citizens and that
case has always stood as sort of a blog
so what happened in that case how did we
get in to that mess well this is
basically what happened 1942 I was alive
then I was in San Francisco I can
remember the blackout curtains that my
parents would draw every evening the
Japanese had bombed Pearl Harbor and
people in California were frightened and
they thought there might be an invasion
and indeed
that was a reasonable thing to think
maybe there would be an invasion of
California certainly people thought that
in December of 41 and the beginning of
1942 and people began to write but there
are thousands a hundred thousand
potential fifth columnist right here in
California who are they they're the
Japanese I mean folks of Japanese
ancestry and we can't have them here
when the Japanese are approaching but
their aircraft carriers and submarines
and who was saying that the LA Times
walter lippmann earl warren hmm earl
warren I have to say later said it was
the worst thing he'd ever done in his
life I took him some time to figure that
out because at the time he made the
argument to a group I think that
included a lot of fruit and vegetable
growers who did have a certain
self-interest because many of the
Japanese also grew fruit and vegetables
and they would soon be removed and that
might help them economically but
nonetheless let's keep that out of it
which I've just put but Warren said the
very fact that a lot of people made this
argument the very fact there has been no
instance of sabotage so far is the proof
that they must be planning something now
that argument
oddly enough had a lot of resonance at
the time the person in charge of
California was general DeWitt he was in
the Presidio of San Francisco and he
wrote a report and in his report he said
he thought there were instances in which
unidentified signals probably from the
Japanese on shore had been going out to
submarines and he thought there were
instances of sabotage where in fact
Japanese on Japanese ancestry when I say
that on the shore had played a role and
therefore the thing to do is to remove
the Japanese from California and send
them east to the east of California or
to the basin and where should we keep
them will build camps hmm
that was his recommendation it was
debated in Washington for a while but
one of the strongest opponents
interestingly enough J Edgar Hoover head
of the FBI he said there's no need for
this we have this problem well under
control
but ultimately the Secretary of War and
thus attorney general Biddle Harry
Stimson at the advice of John J McCloy
thought this was a very reasonable idea
and Roosevelt signed the order and they
were removed they were ordered first
there was a curfew which went on for a
few weeks and then there was a an order
saying you cannot leave California and
the way it took form was you can't leave
California if you're of Japanese
ancestry next order you can't stay in
California what we can't leave and we
can't stay I'll wait there are a few
places here that you can stay one is Ken
Fran racetrack another is Santa Anita
and they were put in those places and
once they were there they're putting
trucks and trains and they're brought
two camps further east
now that happened I can remember my
mother driving me down by Dan Fran
racetrack and saying that's where they
put the Japanese in the war and approval
was not in her tone of voice but they
went and there were very few people very
few including the Japanese themselves
who really complained about it too much
they didn't want to cause a lot of fuss
now suddenly a few decided to bring a
test case there was her bio she it was
Korematsu it was mrs. endo now
Hirabayashi completely loyal American
lived up in Washington state of
Washington and he said well walked
himself into the FBI and he says I'm not
going to obey the curfew and I'm not
reporting and they then charged him with
a crime under this statute there was a
trial and he was convicted and the judge
said I'm gonna
and shoo - 30 days on each and he made a
little mistake here his lawyer and he
said you know he was going to make it
two consecutive 30 day terms and he said
no in fights - 30 day terms I have to
I'd rather have a longer term because
the shorter term means I have to stay in
the county jail and the longer term
means I can be on a work camp and so he
said okay I'll make it one 60 day term
on each and they'll run concurrently all
right
goes to the work camp Korematsu in San
Francisco he comes in this is I'm not
gonna do this I'm not gonna report I'm
sure you can't just put me in a camp
because I am a jack I'm a citizen I'm an
American citizen I was born in Oakland I
went to City College of Los Angeles I
mean this is ridiculous and he found a
lawyer the lawyer was Ernie Bezeq who by
chance used to play poker with my father
but and her Ernie Bezeq was the was the
Civil Liberties Union lawyer in San
Francisco and the ACLU for a variety of
internal reasons wouldn't let him
represent the ACLU in that case and he
couldn't he had to put his own name on
the brief but anyway he brought the case
and eventually these cases first yura be
ah she finds its way to the Supreme
Court and what the Supreme Court said is
well it's a curfew
it's a curfew it took place just after
these bombing there might have been good
reason for it and then it quotes to its
report you know about the sabotage and
the radio signals and so forth and we
cannot say it's beyond the War Powers
even though it's racially oriented
you're a VI she's convicted what about
going to the camp well us at the court
the sentence is concurrent so we don't
have to reach that issue hmm that's
right a year later it's now 1944
Korematsu case reaches the Supreme Court
of the United States court says
you're sent to the camp yes he objects
to that yes well we already decided this
in Hirabayashi black rights in the
opinion now tell you something very
interesting about that case which I
learned as I read about it by 1944 it
was pretty apparent that the reasons
that had been given in 1942 were to put
it mildly
pretty good rubbish here's why we think
that there were two lawyers in the
Department of Justice anise and Burling
were their names and they were really
outraged by what DeWitt kept writing
which had a strong racial overtone I
mean really racially even the Department
of Defense was getting fed up with
DeWitt and they transferred him to a
different place but his reports were
still out there so innocent Burling take
the reports and they read them and they
said well these say that the but there
were broadcasts going from the Japanese
to submarines off shore hmm how does he
know that let's give it to the FCC and
this says sabotage let's ask the FBI two
weeks later the FCC comes in with a
report like that what does it say says
there were no instances none zero not
one broadcast this is what why did they
think that I said well because because
there were some young privates just got
into the army and they didn't know how
to work our equipment and we've tracked
every single one this is so how did you
do this in just two weeks if we didn't
do it in two weeks we did it in December
at 1941 in January of 1942 and we gave
that to do it and he knew it at the time
same thing with the sabotage it came
back that J Edgar Hoover knew these
instances some of them took place after
the camp set up everybody's in the camps
they were not involving the Japanese and
Hoover was saying we said to do it at
the time we have this under control
there are a thousand people we'd like to
arrest
but not 70,000 please this is ridiculous
and we told him that at the time now
these two lawyers had a problem I mean
they're officers of the court and what
they did was they said we want to write
a footnote in here and the footnote is
going to say to the court
don't take judicial notice of anything
into its final report it said a recital
of the circumstances justifying the
evacuation as a matter of military
necessity is in several respects
particularly with reference to the use
of illegal radio transmitters and
shorter ships signaling by persons of
Japanese ancestry in conflict with
information in the possession of the
Department of Justice he wrote that in
the brief at this point the Defense
Department had an absolute fit and who
was called in to mediate this dispute
the person who was the Attorney General
in the Department of Justice in charge
of war Herbert J Wexler and Herbert a
waxer ended up mediating this fight so
what appeared in the brief was the
following we have specifically resided
in this brief the facts relating to the
justification for the evacuation of
which we asked the court to take
judicial notice and will rely upon the
final report only to the extent it
relates to such facts that's a little
more obscure but in that brief wrote
this in the oral argument the AC of you
did a pretty good job and they got
charlie horse key and charley horse key
in the oral argument holds this brief up
and reads them the footnote and says I'm
telling you what this means this means
that what DeWitt said is a bunch of
rubbish and they will not stand behind
it and the court had a pretty good idea
and then the there was some
japanese-american associations you know
by this time the nittany see were
fighting in Europe and they were the
most decorated ever and they come back
to their homes and the home wouldn't be
there and they'd go out to see the the
the
and probably some of you saw this in the
films they went out to the camp where
their parents are and and there was
barbed wire around it and the camp
commander is pretty sympathetic and they
say how can you keep my parents in this
place where I'm out there risking my
life for this country and the commander
said well it's the United States Army
for you know I mean that's it was gone
but the feeling in the United States
that this should be going on and the
court is told in the briefs bit by bit
that there is no justification but the
court upheld it and it upheld it over
three dissents why did it uphold it
that's what I think is so interesting
and I think the answer is found in the
dissents
so what Jackson says in the dissent his
dissent is as it's famous for this he
says you can't uphold this the war is
over there's no need
this is 1944 it isn't 1942 and he says
the military let them do what they want
if it were 1942 they're gonna do it we
can't control that but it's our job to
after the military does what it thinks
is necessary to come in and say it's
unlawful and that's what we should do
here that's what I'd call super
pragmatism I don't like that super
pragmatic approach why don't I like it
because for one thing it's telegraphing
to the military that sometimes they may
have to take steps that are outside the
law and if that's true I certainly don't
want to judge saying that I mean they
face this problem in Israel and they
think it's a thoroughly bad idea to say
to the military you have to take steps
to save the country that are outside the
law and at the same time if the military
really needs to do something maybe they
wouldn't do it because they won't want
to be turned aside later the president
United States pays a big political price
if he ever was willing to pay it for
doing something that the court is later
going to say is unconstitutional so this
is a system that might not work too well
and at least in Israel they've tried to
make the law
respond to the military necessity so you
don't get into a situation where you
have to violate the law in order to save
the country
well said Jackson this opinion is going
to stand here he had great phrases this
opinion which I'm descending from is
gonna stand here like a loaded gun the
precedent is like a loaded gun waiting
for the next time well in fact it isn't
like a loaded gun because there's one
person the United States of America I
think who think the Korematsu is a good
precedent for anything I mean I'm not
sure how much of a loaded gun it is then
there is Murphy and what Murphy does is
Murphy goes through systematically and
says there's no justification there's no
justification for this whatsoever
problem what about the next case
frankfurter says we can't review these
one at a time
we can't review them I mean either
Roosevelt runs the war or the judges run
the war we can't do it you see the
problem they can't figure out I think
how to bring this under control
so in Korematsu it was an effort to get
accountability but the effort failed
because the court couldn't figure out
how to make them accountable last five
minutes let me compare briefly what the
court I think has been trying to do with
the Guantanamo cases what we've had four
cases in each of those cases the
detainee has brought a case and really
the detainee has one case number one the
detainee says I'm entitled to file a
writ of habeas corpus the government
says no you're not the statute doesn't
apply the court says well you can file a
writ of habeas corpus
why because Guantanamo is part of the
United States does this mean
that anyone on a battlefield can file a
writ of habeas corpus no the court
doesn't say it says we're talking about
Guantanamo all we're saying is you can
file a writ we're not telling you
whether you're gonna win we're not
telling you what the conditions are
under which you'd win were not gonna say
more than that case number two Hamdi an
American citizen he's being held not in
Guantanamo anymore but in a naval brig
he says can't hold me why not well no
power under the Constitution the court
says if we can hold you can hold him if
he's an enemy combatant if he's an enemy
combatant and there are active
hostilities going on as there were when
he was captured in Afghanistan you can
hold him he says but I wasn't an active
combatant I was just a peaceful farmer
well since the army why did you have a
bazooka peaceful farmers need bazookas
in Afghanistan but but the the the point
is there's a disagreement as to the
facts the court says if there's a
disagreement you have to give him a fair
hearing what's a fair hearing a fair
hearing is a neutral decision-maker an
opportunity to present proofs and
argument weird you have to give him this
fair hearing
won't you be more detailed than that no
the court is not more detailed than that
third case that comes up they want to
try the government bin Laden's driver
named honden in a special military
tribunal a special tribunal not a
court-martial not an ordinary court can
you do it well says the court we're not
going to tell you constitutionally
because we've looked at the statute and
the statute says that you can use a
military commission only when another
statute permits it and we don't see one
or
you're considering a violation of the
laws of war and that isn't what you're
trying him for but we don't have to go
further than that
Congress can pass another statute if it
wants we're not saying it would be
constitutional we're not saying they
should but this is a matter of what the
statute says fourth case Congress did
get around to responding to the third
case and in the fourth case it says
they're going to be military commissions
and it also says that what they will not
be is review in the Supreme Court by
habeas corpus hmm now the court has to
reach a real problem because the
Constitution says that Congress cannot
suspend the writ of habeas corpus except
in time of insurrection or rebellion
which wasn't here and have they violated
that provision the issue was pretty
complicated because they provided for
some other kinds of review and the
question was was that equivalent to
habeas corpus which we thought it wasn't
but the key question was does that
Constitution protect the people assuring
them right of habeas corpus when they're
in Guantanamo and the court says yes no
the dissent well then you're saying all
over the world you have an armed war and
somebody's gonna start filing for habeas
corpus no the court said about that
didn't say yes it didn't say no he just
said these matters are pragmatic matters
I didn't write that decision I thought
was a good decision Justice Kennedy
wrote it and I counted the number of
times he used the word pragmatic and it
was approximately 12 at least and whole
phrases whole phrases consisted of that
idea the judgment about where habeas
corpus applies in time of war or
national security is a pragmatic
judgment now what I'm trying to show you
very briefly is a contrast what the
court was doing in that case I think
was trying to keep a string a string of
accountability decide as little as you
can because who knows what will happen
by way of national security the Supreme
Court is not an expert on national
security and again and again justices
the court have written to the effect
that the Constitution is not a suicide
pact and we have a president whose job
it is to assure that security but but
but what happens were the basic civil
right that the court is there to protect
is interfered with by this decision
the Korematsu court says no choice if
it's the president or the court to run
the war it has to be the president what
you've seen happening in my opinion over
the last few years is an effort to keep
a string of accountability on the
president even in that time of war now
what have I tried to outline I've tried
to outline eight real approaches what
are they approaches I've said that there
are certain concepts that will help work
what are those concepts in the area of
statutes it has to do with purpose in
the area of administrative law it has to
do with comparative expertise viewed in
light of a statute in the area of
federalism it has to do something with
this notion of subsidiarity when you
start talking about lower courts and
higher courts the key word is
specialization when you start talking
about the past and precedent you talk
about stability and you talk about it in
terms of a pragmatic judgment as to win
you overrule when you talk about
dispositions provisions in the
Constitution that protects civil rights
the key word is values and maybe
proportionality if you have to do some
balancing and when you talk about the
President as president you remember the
word accountability but again much
pragmatic judgment and an effort at
least to keep the President on a string
while recognizing the knee
that could be real for a power in the
president and the military to give the
protection that's necessary I put all
those things together and I don't say
that those are the only ways you could
approach problems legal problems in our
court but I do say that they're coherent
they're consistent with each other they
do help in many areas produce decisions
that help the government work a little
bit better and therefore I can say that
at least looking back at my own
decisions creates a kind of coherent
role a whole grouped around the notion
of trying to produce decisions that will
in fact make the law work reasonably
well permanent values changing
circumstances work reasonably well now
who knows whether they're been
successful that will be for futures to
decide but it's at least an approach and
that's an approach I think if it works
and works fairly well can help the court
produce better decisions if it produces
better decisions in the sense that they
work and they cooperate better with
other with other agencies with other
parts of the government then we have a
government that will in fact be workable
and if the government is workable the
public is more likely to accept the
court as an institution and follow it
even when it disagrees so that's what I
think of is the courts responsibility
one last word I should just end right
now but I can't because then we'll leave
you the impression that I think I have a
magic solution and I don't have a magic
solution nobody could think nobody could
think but the court doing a little bit
of that my way or a little bit of it
some other way is really going to make
that much difference
because what does make a difference
ultimately to people accepting the court
is their decision to make
a kind of faith of the following
accepting an institution that they know
will decide things that they don't like
at least some of the time
now that's very very hard to get people
to understand why that could be in their
interest so I think of the court as
floating on a sea of public opinion and
that public opinion cannot zero cannot
affect the decision of an individual
case but that public opinion of support
has to be there for the institution to
survive and that's why I think the best
we can do though I'd love people to
adopt approach I have is to say well
there is an approach that may help some
but more important than that is what I
said at the beginning of the lecture
which is so easy to say and it sounds
like a dull word but it's called
education and it's called participate in
the government and it's called
understand our institutions and it's
called the opposite of learning that
civics is no longer being taught in a
lot of high schools and it's called the
opposite of learning that more and more
judicial campaigns are fought on the
basis of who can contribute the most
money because they're not going to have
an independent judiciary with that kind
of system and it's for the kind of
participation and understanding that
will in fact lead people to understand
through experience what their
governments about this democracy and it
also suggests that you law students or
teachers and even judges can help at
least a little bit by trying to explain
to people what it is we do what it is
the judges do what the law is about and
why they might even support following it
even when the decision goes against them